Joe Franklin?
Ira Glass：Joe Franklin？
I'm ready.
Joe Franklin：我准备好了。
It's Ira Glass here.
Ira Glass：我是Ira Glass。
Oh, you're the emcee on the show, Ira.
Joe Franklin：哦，你是节目的主持人，Ira。
I am the emcee on the show. Yes.
Ira Glass：我是节目的主持人。没错。
Oh great. Ira? I-R-A, Ira?
Joe Franklin：太棒了。Ira？I-R-A，Ira吗？
Ira, I-R-A.
Ira Glass：Ira，I-R-A。
Oh, great. Now hold on one second, Ira. Don't go away. Hello? [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Call me after 3 o'clock. I have great news for you. Ira.
Joe Franklin：哦，太好了。现在等一下，Ira。别走开。喂？[听不清楚]。3点以后再给我打电话。我有好消息要告诉你，Ira。
Yes.
Ira Glass：好的。
So listen, Tony. If the phone rings, take it in the back. And then come out and tell me who it is. Just say, Joe's being with a camera crew. Just for about 10 minutes. We'll do about five minutes, 10 minutes, right, Ira?
Joe Franklin：听着，Tony。如果电话响了，去后台接。然后出来告诉我那是谁。就说Joe正在和摄制组在一起。大概10分钟。我们就做五分钟，10分钟，对吧，Ira？
That's right.
Ira Glass：没错。
Well, one great thing about starting a new show is utter anonymity. Nobody really knows what to expect from you. This interviewee did not know us from Adam.
Ira Glass：嗯，开启一个新节目的一大好处就是完全默默无闻。没人知道会对你有什么期待。这位受访者根本不认识我们是谁。
OK, we're what? About a minute. We're one minute five into the new show. Right now, it is stretching in front of us, a perfect future yet to be fulfilled. An uncharted little world. A little baby coming into the world, no little scars on it or anything.
Ira Glass：好了，我们现在进展如何？大约一分钟。新节目已经开始一分零五秒了。此刻，它展现在我们面前，是一个尚未实现的完美未来。一个未知的微小世界。就像一个刚来到这个世界的小婴儿，身上没有任何伤疤之类的东西。
Nobody hearing my words right now is thinking, "Oh, man, remember that show, back when it used to be good? That show, I never missed that show back in the old days, back in the first couple years before it got so-called popular. Back when it was still good."
Ira Glass：现在听到我说话的人，没有人会想：“噢，天哪，还记得那个节目吗，在它还不错的时候？那个节目，在早期还没那么出名的时候，我从没错过。那时它还很好。”
No, actually, I think that force, that human desire to say that is so strong, to say that "I was there back when that show was good," that force is so strong, it is so basic to who we are as people that I know-- OK, what are we? We are two minutes into the program-- I know that somewhere out there, one or two of you are saying, "Oh, sure. I used to listen to that show back in the first 30 seconds, back when it used to be really good. Remember back when they used to do all that crazy stuff? When they had that guy on the phone? Remember back then?"
Ira Glass：不，实际上，我认为那种力量，那种想要说出“我那时候就在看这节目”的人类欲望非常强烈，这种力量如此基本，深深扎根于我们作为人的本质中，以至于我知道——好吧，我们进行到哪了？节目开始了大约两分钟——我知道在某个地方，你们中间有一两个人会说：“噢，当然。我过去常听这节目，在前30秒的时候，那时候它真的很好。还记得他们过去做那些疯狂事情的时候吗？当他们让那个人在电话上的时候？还记得那时候吗？”
Well, from WBEZ, in the glorious city of Chicago, Illinois. The name of this show is Your Radio Playhouse. I'm your emcee. I'm your emcee, Ira Glass.
Ira Glass：好了，来自伊利诺伊州芝加哥市辉煌的WBEZ电台。这个节目的名字是《你的广播剧场》（Your Radio Playhouse）。我是你们的主持人。我是你们的主持人，Ira Glass。
OK, the idea of this show, this new little show, is stories, some by journalists and documentary producers, like myself, some just regular people telling their own little stories, some by artists, and writers, and performers of all different kinds. And the idea is we're going to bring you stuff you're not going to find anywhere else. And there is also going to be music.
Ira Glass：好了，这个节目——这个小小的全新节目的构想是故事，有些来自记者和纪录片制作人，比如我自己；有些来自普通人讲述他们自己的小故事；有些来自各种艺术家、作家和表演者。我们的想法是带给你们在别处找不到的内容。而且还会有音乐。
And tonight's show, we thought that we would have a theme. Tonight's show is going to be New Beginnings. And to kick things off, I called the man who's had, as best as anybody can tell, the longest running program in the history of television. His name is Joe Franklin, and his program ran for 43 years on local television in New York. And he claims that he invented the talk show format. And I called him to get some advice on how to create a long-running, healthy program.
Ira Glass：今晚的节目，我们想设定一个主题。今晚的主题是“新的开端”。为了开个好头，我打电话给了一个人，据大家所知，他拥有电视史上播放时间最长的节目。他的名字叫Joe Franklin，他的节目在纽约当地电视台播出了43年。他声称自己发明了访谈节目的形式。我打电话给他，是为了讨教如何打造一个长青且健康的节目。
I've been called in many times to give a sort of a Dean, the elder statesman, even though I'm still a young kid. But I've been called in to give this kind of advice to new kids on the block. Conan O'Brien had me on his first show. And people like that. There's no guidance. It's a matter of paying attention.
Joe Franklin：我曾多次被请去担任某种导师，或者资深元老，尽管我还是个年轻人。但我被请去给这些新人提供这种建议。Conan O'Brien在他的第一期节目中就请了我。像那样的人。没有指南。关键在于用心。
Your voice, I've heard so much about the sparkle, about the energy in your voice. The voice, on radio especially, is everything. And when the guest is sitting with you, you've got to look into his eyes. Many times, you get an author on there who's begrudgingly sitting there. He'd rather be home in his ivory tower.
Joe Franklin：你的声音，我听过很多关于你声音中那种火花和能量的评价。声音，尤其是在广播中，就是一切。当嘉宾坐在你对面时，你必须直视他的眼睛。很多时候，你会遇到一位心不甘情不愿坐在那里的作者。他宁愿待在自己象牙塔里的家里。
And above all, get the plug fast. Otherwise, he's worried you're not going to make the plug for the book. And I created a line, Ira, that's been picked up by George Burns. I always said, the main ingredient for longevity in the talk show field, where the mortality rate is so staggering, the main ingredient is sincerity. And once you learn to fake that, then you got it made. I made that up. And I just played it by ear. I was a natural born talker, I guess.
Joe Franklin：最重要的是，快点让他插播广告。否则，他会担心你没有为他的书做宣传。我创造了一句台词，Ira，后来被George Burns沿用了。我一直说，访谈节目领域长寿的主要秘诀——这个行业的死亡率高得惊人——主要秘诀就是真诚。一旦你学会了伪装真诚，你就成功了。那是我想出来的。我只是临场发挥。我想我是一个天生的演说家。
So let me just summarize what I'm getting from you. You're saying you should just pay attention, look people in the eye, be sincere when I'm on the air, get in the plug early.
Ira Glass：那么让我总结一下我从你这里学到的。你是说我应该用心，直视人们的眼睛，在广播时保持真诚，并尽早插播广告。
That's the key. And don't look in their nose or their belly button. Look right in the eye. Eye contact is everything. And as I say, it's a lot of fun.
Joe Franklin：这就是关键。而且不要盯着他们的鼻子或肚脐看。直视眼睛。眼神交流就是一切。正如我所说，这很有趣。
And I never called anybody in my life to come on to my show. And I'm sure that they'll be coming to you too. I heard about you, and I called you and wanted to wish you good look, Ira. Imagine the thrill of John F. Kennedy walking into my studio. Richard Nixon. Ronald Reagan, five times. And Bing Crosby.
Joe Franklin：我这辈子从没打过电话请人上我的节目。我相信他们也会主动来找你。我听说过你，所以我打电话给你，想祝你好运，Ira。想象一下John F. Kennedy走进我演播室时的那种激动吧。还有Richard Nixon。Ronald Reagan，五次。以及Bing Crosby。
And I've got a major book out right now, by the way, Ira, called Up Late with Joe Franklin from Simon & Schuster. And if you find a copy in the store--
Joe Franklin：顺便说一句，Ira，我刚出了一本大书，由Simon & Schuster出版，书名是《与Joe Franklin彻夜长谈》（Up Late with Joe Franklin）。如果你在书店里找到了副本……
You see now, I guess I've sort of messed that one up, because I didn't let you get in your plug early.
Ira Glass：你看，我想我把那件事搞砸了，因为我没让你尽早插播广告。
See, that is my fault. I got it in toward the bitter end. It's like Duke Ellington. He always used to have his dessert at the beginning of the meal. Duke Ellington said, because he would never have no room for it at the end. So he had his dessert at the beginning. Who is it? Well, no, good news, 6 o'clock.
Joe Franklin：看，那是我的错。我在最后关头才提出来。这就像Duke Ellington。他过去总是把甜点放在餐前吃。Duke Ellington说，因为到最后他准没胃口了。所以他餐前吃甜点。那是谁？嗯，不，好消息，6点钟。
Well, Joe Franklin, thank you very much for being with us on our premier show.
Ira Glass：好吧，Joe Franklin，非常感谢你参加我们的首播节目。
Ira, I'm going to be a listener and a fan. And let's always be in touch.
Joe Franklin：Ira，我将成为你的听众和粉丝。让我们保持联系。
[MUSIC - "DESTINATION MOON" BY DINAH WASHINGTON]
Joe Franklin：[音乐 - Dinah Washington演唱的《DESTINATION MOON》]
All right, Your Radio Playhouse. All right. I'm making eye contact with you right-- wait, how does Joe put it? Wait a second.
Ira Glass：好的，《你的广播剧场》。好的。我正与你进行眼神交流——等等，Joe是怎么说的？等一下。
Look right in the eye. Eye contact is everything.
Joe Franklin：直视眼睛。眼神交流就是一切。
I am making eye contact with you right now. That is just how much I have already learned. OK, so the thing about new beginnings is that there are the ones that we actually undertake and then there are the ones that we just wish for. And the ones that we wish for pretty much outnumber the ones that we really undertake.
Ira Glass：我现在确实在和你进行眼神交流。这就是我已经学到的东西。好了，关于新的开端，有一些是我们真正着手去做的，另一些则是我们仅仅是期盼的。而我们期盼的那些，数量远超过我们真正付诸实践的。
Well, Kevin Kelly spent most of his twenties wandering around Asia. He was basically wandering around as a freelance photographer. And he found himself photographing a lot of religious ceremonies and drawn to religious ceremonies of all sorts. And he says that he was really confused about what he believed. And he was the kind of person who had always dreamt about a new beginning, where he wouldn't struggle with these questions.
Ira Glass：嗯，Kevin Kelly在二十多岁时大部分时间都在亚洲游荡。他基本上是以自由摄影师的身份四处流浪。他发现自己拍摄了许多宗教仪式，并被各种宗教仪式所吸引。他说他对自己的信仰感到非常困惑。他一直梦想着一个全新的开端，在那里他不必再纠结于这些问题。
I would get twisted and caught up. And these things were in the background, consuming me. And actually, I found that I could think about little else for many, many months, that behind all that I was doing, there was always this unresolved question of was God real. And if he was real, then how could we ignore him? And if we were trying to not ignore him, what would we do? And if he was real, then what about these other things that people said about God?
Kevin Kelly：我会变得纠结并陷入其中。这些事情萦绕在心头，消耗着我。实际上，我发现有许多个月里，我几乎想不出别的事情。在我所做的一切背后，总有一个悬而未决的问题：上帝是真的吗？如果他是真的，那我们怎么能忽视他？如果我们试图不忽视他，我们该做什么？如果他是真的，那人们关于上帝的其他说法又该怎么解释？
We will not attempt to answer these questions, by the way, in this hour. I just want to just give you a sense of scope here, just modest scope. But what we want to talk about is what happened to Kevin Kelly. What happened is that at the age of 27, all of this changed when he came into Jerusalem on the eve of Easter and Passover. It was the same weekend. And flocks of people are coming into the city.
Ira Glass：顺便说一句，在这个小时里，我们不会试图回答这些问题。我只是想让你了解一下范围，仅仅是适度的范围。但我们要谈论的是Kevin Kelly身上发生了什么。在他27岁那年，这一切在他进入耶路撒冷迎接复活节和逾越节前夕时改变了。那是同一个周末。大群的人涌入这座城市。
So I entered Jerusalem on Easter with a simple expectation that I was going to photograph another religious ceremony, another religious festival. And then, for various reasons, I got locked out of my hostel room. They had a curfew. And I didn't make it back in time. And I was in quite a fix because I was a stranger in this very strange town. When it happened, I didn't have enough money to stay elsewhere, nor did I even have knowledge of where to go.
Kevin Kelly：所以我在复活节那天进入了耶路撒冷，怀着一个简单的期望，就是拍摄另一个宗教仪式，另一个宗教节日。然后，由于各种原因，我被锁在了宿舍房间外面。他们有宵禁。我没来得及赶回去。我陷入了相当尴尬的境地，因为我是一个身处异乡的陌生人。当事情发生时，我既没有足够的钱住别处，也不知道该去哪里。
So I wandered the Old Town of Jerusalem at night, which had been shuttered up and was like a time machine. It was as if I had been transported back to the 15th century, because all the souvenir vendors were gone, and what was left were the labyrinthian paths of cobbled passageways. And I wandered around for a number of hours, and it was getting colder. Eventually, I found myself at the one place that was still open, which was some of the churches. And particularly, after wandering around until about 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning, I finally settled into the Church of the Holy Scepter, which is called and viewed as the church built over the mound where Jesus Christ was crucified.
Kevin Kelly：于是我在夜晚徘徊在耶路撒冷的旧城，那里已经关门闭户，就像一台时间机器。仿佛我被传送回了15世纪，因为所有的纪念品小贩都不见了，剩下的是鹅卵石铺就的迷宫般的小巷。我徘徊了几个小时，天越来越冷了。最终，我发现自己来到了唯一还开着的地方，那就是一些教堂。特别是，在一直徘徊到凌晨2点或3点后，我最终在圣墓教堂安顿下来，这里被视为建在耶稣基督被钉死在十字架上的土丘之上的教堂。
And I was getting very tired. And there weren't many people around. And so eventually, I laid myself out on about the only flat area that was left, which was this marble slab underneath some pendants that had incense on them. And this was presumably the slab that commemorated the exact positioning of the crosses. So I slept there. I slept on the crucifixion spot on that night because it was the only place-- they had no place in the inn.
Kevin Kelly：我感到非常疲惫。周围没多少人。所以最终，我躺在了仅剩的平坦区域上，那是某些挂着香炉的吊坠下方的一块大理石板。这大概就是纪念十字架确切位置的石板。所以我睡在那里。那天晚上我睡在钉十字架的地方，因为那是唯一的地方——客店里没有空位了。
I slept there until early morning, when the activity started to increase, and people started coming in. And I went out and followed the crowd where it was going when they were going out to the tombs area in Jerusalem. And I went out. And there were some folding chairs set up in front of this tomb area. And as the sun was coming up on that Easter morning, I was staring at empty tombs. And for a reason that I can not comprehend, as I sat on that chair contemplating this view of the early sun morning coming into the empty tombs, all that I had been wrestling with for the past many, many years in thinking about religion sort of became resolved in my mind. And at that very moment, I believed that Jesus Christ had, indeed, risen from those tombs.
Kevin Kelly：我一直睡到清晨，活动开始增多，人们开始进来。我走出去，跟随人群前往耶路撒冷的墓地。我出去了。在墓地区域前架设了一些折叠椅。当复活节早晨的太阳升起时，我盯着空荡荡的坟墓。出于一种我无法理解的原因，当我坐在椅子上凝视着清晨的阳光照进空坟墓的景象时，我过去多年来在思考宗教问题上所纠结的一切，在我的脑海中迎刃而解。就在那一刻，我相信耶稣基督确实从那些坟墓中复活了。
In an instant, the tension of trying to figure things out was resolved, because now, suddenly, everything was figured out. It was as if you had been working on a problem for a long time and suddenly the answer was there. And it was very clear that was the answer. And although there were many things that were still not clear to you, you were very certain that you were on the right path.
Kevin Kelly：那一瞬间，试图弄清楚事情真相的紧张感消失了，因为现在，突然之间，一切都清晰了。就像你长期致力于解决一个难题，答案突然就出现了。而且很明显那就是答案。虽然还有许多事情你仍然不清楚，但你非常确定自己走在正确的道路上。
Having that realization that I believe that Jesus Christ had actually risen from those tombs did not settle 1,001 other things about what one was supposed to do with that, what I was supposed to do with that. Did that mean I was supposed to be a monk? Did that mean I was supposed to be an evangelist?
Kevin Kelly：意识到我相信耶稣基督真的从那些坟墓中复活了，并不能解决关于一个人应该如何处理这件事的1001个其他问题，我该怎么处理这件事呢？这意味着我应该成为一名僧侣吗？这意味着我应该成为一名传教士吗？
Did that mean that I had to immediately renounce all that I had, and get into sackcloths and ashes, and march out into the desert? All that was left unopened. And that is, in fact, what occupied my mind as I went back to my hostel to lay down and think about. Because I had no clue what it really meant to me ultimately, and that's what I was pondering when I was laying there napping. And I wouldn't say it was a voice, but there was an idea that came into my mind that just would not go away, and that was that I should live as if I would die in six months, that I should really, truly live. And that I could not tell for certain whether I would really die, but that either way, I should live as if I was going to die. And so that was the assignment.
Kevin Kelly：这意味着我必须立即放弃我所有的一切，披上麻布，撒上灰烬，走向沙漠吗？这一切都悬而未决。而这正是当我回到宿舍躺下思考时，占据我大脑的东西。因为我根本不知道这对最终的我意味着什么，那正是我躺在那小憩时所思考的问题。我不会说那是一个声音，但确实有一个念头进入了我的脑海，挥之不去，那就是我应该像只剩六个月生命一样去生活，我应该真正地、切实地生活。而我无法确定自己是否真的会死，但无论如何，我都应该像我就要死了一样去生活。这就是任务。
I'm a pretty rational person. I'm pretty logical. And after thinking the thought that I should live as if I was going to die in six months, the first thought that comes to my head was, "Well, that's pretty silly. I have no evidence whatsoever. I could live like I'm going to die in six months and not die at all. It would just be an interesting exercise."
Kevin Kelly：我是一个相当理性的人。我很讲逻辑。在想到我应该像六个月后就要死了一样生活后，我脑海中浮现的第一个念头是：“嗯，那太傻了。我没有任何证据。我可以像六个月后就要死了一样生活，但实际上根本不会死。那只会是一个有趣的练习。”
But at the same time, it was equally probable that I might die in six months. It happened all the time. There was no guarantee that I wouldn't die. And so fairly quickly, I decided that I could not settle that issue of whether I would really die or not, or just think that I was going to die in six months, and that, in either case, the important thing was to live as if I really believed that I was going to die in six months, which is what I set out to do.
Kevin Kelly：但与此同时，我也同样有可能在六个月后死去。这种事随时都在发生。没有任何保证我不会死。所以很快，我决定我无法解决关于我是否真的会死的问题，或者仅仅是认为我六个月后会死，无论哪种情况，重要的是像我真的相信自己六个月后会死那样生活，这就是我着手去做的事情。
The next couple days, I had the joyous experience of saying to myself, "OK, what do I do for six months if I have only six months to live?" And the answers to that surprised me as much as the assignment, because after thinking that through and contemplating it, the conclusion that I came to was that what I wanted to do for six months was to go home and be ordinary, to go back to my parents, to help them take out the trash, and trim the hedges, and move furniture around, and to be with them. And I was really shocked by that, because I thought that with six months to live, I would climb Mount Everest, or I would go scuba diving to the depths of the ocean, or get in a speedboat and see how fast I could go. But instead, I wanted to go back home and be with my family for that time.
Kevin Kelly：接下来的几天，我有幸对自己说：“好吧，如果我只有六个月的生命，我该做什么？”这些答案让我和那个任务本身一样感到惊讶，因为在深思熟虑后，我得出的结论是：我这六个月想做的事，是回家过平凡的生活，回到父母身边，帮他们倒垃圾，修剪树篱，搬动家具，和他们在一起。我真的为此感到震惊，因为我以为如果只剩六个月的生命，我会去爬珠穆朗玛峰，或者潜入深海，或者跳进快艇看看能跑多快。但相反，我只想回家，在剩下的时间里和家人在一起。
I, of course, did not tell anybody my crazy idea. This is, in fact, the first time I'm really talking about it publicly. Because it's a very scary and alarming idea. And I never told anybody why I was coming home.
Kevin Kelly：当然，我没有告诉任何人我这个疯狂的想法。事实上，这是我第一次真正公开谈论它。因为它是一个非常可怕且令人不安的想法。我从未告诉任何人我为什么要回家。
I got back to where my parents live in New Jersey, and things were unbelievably ordinary. And yet, I found myself relishing the ordinariness and finding it in some ways as exotic as anything that I had traveled to see. I helped around the house. I dug up shrubs. I worked on a deck. I moved furniture, washed dishes.
Kevin Kelly：我回到了父母在纽泽西州的住处，一切都不可思议地平凡。然而，我发现自己很享受这种平凡，在某种程度上，我觉得它和我曾去过的地方一样充满异国情调。我帮家里做杂务，挖灌木，修理露台，搬家具，洗碗。
And I was intending to spend my last remaining six months at home getting to know my parents better and myself, hopefully. But about three months into that, my travel urges, I guess, got the better of me. And what I was most concerned about was I wanted to see my brothers and sisters. I had four brothers and sisters. And they were scattered all across the country. And so I felt very strongly that I wanted to see them before I died. And I got the idea that the way to see them was to ride my bicycle across the country and visit them on bicycle.
Kevin Kelly：我本来打算在家里度过剩下的六个月，更好地了解父母，并希望了解自己。但大约过了三个月，我想我的旅行冲动战胜了我。我最关心的是我想见见我的兄弟姐妹。我有四个兄弟姐妹。他们分散在全国各地。所以我强烈地感觉到，在死前我想见见他们。我产生了一个想法，骑自行车横跨全国去探望他们。
But before I did that, I made up a will to dispose of the little things that I had. And I had some money left over. And one of the things I did with that money was I went to the bank and got some cashier's checks for $500 and $1,000. And I mailed the money to various people anonymously as gifts. And I think giving away those thousands of dollars was the first true act of charity I had ever done. Because there was absolutely no way for any kind of gratitude or elevated feelings to come back to me, because the people had no idea who had sent them that money.
Kevin Kelly：但在我这么做之前，我立了一份遗嘱来处理我的一点点财产。我还有些剩钱。我用那些钱做的一件事就是去了银行，买了一些500美元和1000美元的本票。我匿名把钱邮寄给不同的人作为礼物。我想，捐出那几千美元是我做过的第一个真正的慈善行为。因为我没有任何获得感谢或高尚情感的可能，因为那些人根本不知道是谁寄给他们那笔钱的。
It was really remarkable to see the consequences of getting an anonymous gift like that. Because when you get a check for $1,000 in the mail, you immediately become suspicious of all your friends of having given that to you. And so there's this suspicion of charity, suspicion of goodness that starts to infect the people that are around you. And you look at someone, you think, "Hm, I wonder if he gave me that $1,000?"
看到收到匿名捐赠后的后果，真是太引人注目了。因为当你在邮件里收到一张1000美元的支票时，你立刻就会怀疑是不是身边的某个朋友给你的。于是，这种对慈善、对善意的怀疑，开始感染你周围的人。当你看着某个人时，你会想：“嗯，不知道是不是他给了我那1000美元？”
Does that make sense? You look at them, and you think, "I wonder if he gave me that $1,000?" And then you act really nice to him. And then the next person you see, the next of your friends, you think, "Could this be the person?" And then you act really nice to them.
这说得通吗？你看着他们，心里想：“不知道是不是他给了我那1000美元？”然后你对他表现得非常友好。接着你看到的下一个人，你的下一个朋友，你又会想：“会是这个人吗？”然后你又对他们表现得非常友好。
I almost want to begin a little speech here about let us all now take up this practice. All of us. Everyone within the sound of my voice. If we all could just do this right now, then I would believe that our little radio show, just 19 minutes into the program, had contributed in some way.
我简直想在这里发表一个小小的演讲，号召我们大家都来实行这个做法。我们所有人。每一个听到我声音的人。如果我们现在都能这样做，那么我相信，我们这档小小的广播节目，在开播仅19分钟后，就已经以某种方式做出了贡献。
I had enough money left over to basically pay for food and whatnot on my bicycle journey across America. And the path that I had to visit all my brothers and sisters was not a direct route, going from San Francisco to New York. I actually had to go up to Idaho, and back down to Texas, and then back up through Indiana. So it was a 5,000 mile trip. The day which, coincidentally, was exactly six months from when I had this assignment, was October 31. It was Halloween. And so the plan would be that I would ride back home, so that I would come back to die on the day after Halloween.
我剩下的钱基本上够我在横穿美国的自行车之旅中支付食物和其他费用。为了拜访我所有的兄弟姐妹，我走的并不是从旧金山到纽约的直达路线。我实际上得先去爱达荷州，再折回得克萨斯州，最后再穿过印第安纳州。所以这是一趟5000英里的旅程。这一天，巧合的是，距离我接到这个任务正好过去六个月，也就是10月31日，万圣节。所以计划就是我骑车回家，这样我就能在万圣节过后的那天死去。
I think there are a lot of people who have trouble staying in the present. There are some people who like to slip into the past as a means to perhaps fantasize or escape. And they find that the past is the place that they retreat to. And I often retreat to the future. I was not a person who planned or had a career staged out, or who had a particular woman he wanted to marry some day, or some vision of a house. The future that I found so hard to give up was a much more insidious type.
我认为有很多人难以活在当下。有些人喜欢陷入过去，作为幻想或逃避的一种手段。他们发现过去是他们退缩的地方。而我通常退缩到未来。我不是那种会做规划、有职业生涯安排、或是梦想着未来某天要娶某个特定的女人、又或是对房子有某种愿景的人。我发现那种难以放弃的未来，是一种更阴险的类型。
It was that of I'd like to buy this record because, in the future, I want to hear this song again and again. Or I will read this book, and there are some cool ideas in it because someday I may write an article about this. And it's good to know that. There was a sense in which my entire life was shifted to the future. And the thought of doing something now for the enjoyment, or the pleasures, or the principle of the function of just right now, without any sense at all that it would ever be used again or that it could ever be brought forward, was extremely difficult and disconcerting. And I fought it day by day and tooth by tooth.
那就是，“我想买这张唱片，因为在未来，我想一次又一次地听这首歌”；或者“我会读这本书，里面有一些很酷的观点，因为某天我可能会写一篇关于它的文章”。能知道这一点感觉很好。在某种意义上，我整个人生都转移到了未来。而对于那些为了当下的享受、乐趣或仅仅是为了当下的功能性原则而去做事，且完全没有任何“它以后会被用到”或“它能被带入未来”的感觉，这对我来说极其困难且令人不安。我每天都在竭尽全力地与之抗争。
One of the ways I dealt with this was that I was actually able, by the last weeks, to not think about my life beyond Halloween. There was a way which I had just-- each time a thought came up about something that was beyond this horizon, I just said, "Nope, can't think about it. It doesn't work. We have to dwell in the present."
我应对这种心理的方法之一是，在最后几周，我实际上能够让自己不去想万圣节之后的生活。每当有一个关于地平线之外的事情的想法浮现时，我就说：“不行，不能想。行不通的。我们必须活在当下。”
And at the same time I was doing that, and I was able to do that, I also decided that it was an entirely unnatural and inhumane way to live. And that having a future is part of what being human is about. And that when you take away the future for humans, you take away a lot of their humanness. And that it's not actually a very good thing to live entirely in the present. That one needs to have a past, and one needs to have a future to be fully human.
与此同时，虽然我能做到这一点，但我也认为这是一种完全不自然且没有人性的生活方式。拥有未来是身为人类的一部分。当你剥夺了人类的未来，你就剥夺了他们很大一部分的人性。完全活在当下并不是一件好事。一个人需要拥有过去，也需要拥有未来，才能成为一个完整的人。
It was a journey that began at the tomb of Jesus. And as I set off to my own presumed death, I did, indeed, think about Jesus Christ who, according to the Gospels, surrendered his own life in a very knowing way. So we have the history in the Gospels of Jesus's torment in his soul, as he approached what he knew of his anointed time to die. So it was, again, that very harsh information of knowing when you're going to die.
这是一段始于耶稣坟墓的旅程。当我踏上那段预想中的死亡之路时，我确实想到了耶稣基督，根据《福音书》记载，他以一种非常清醒的方式放弃了自己的生命。所以在《福音书》里，我们有耶稣在接近他所预知的受难时刻时，灵魂所经历的痛苦的记录。所以，再次重申，提前知道自己何时死亡，那是极其残酷的信息。
And Jesus's soul was in great turmoil and pain because of knowing that. And I think I did experience some of that, not because I had the same weight. It was just my own life. But Jesus prayed that this burden be lifted, and there were days when I did pray that, that if I didn't have to die, I really would rather not.
耶稣的灵魂因为预知这一切而陷入极大的动荡和痛苦之中。我想我确实经历了一些类似的感觉，并不是因为我承受着同样的重担。那只是我自己的生活。但耶稣祈祷这个重担能被移去，确实有那么几天，我也那样祈祷过：如果我不必死，我真的宁愿不死。
By late fall, I was pedaling through the Appalachians, and it was getting colder and colder. And my hands were freezing on the bicycles, and there was ice on my tents in the morning when I got up. And as each day went on, I was coming closer and closer to terrain that I was familiar with and that felt like home. And I was riding into New Jersey, and I was elated. I was elated that I had accomplished this long journey. And I was elated that I was home to see my parents.
到了深秋，我骑车穿过阿巴拉契亚山脉，天气越来越冷。我在自行车上冻得手发抖，早上起床时帐篷上结满了冰。随着每一天过去，我越来越接近我熟悉的、感觉像家一样的地方。当我骑车进入新泽西州时，我欣喜若狂。我为自己完成了这漫长的旅程而欣喜若狂。我为能回到家见到父母而欣喜若狂。
And I came in to their house on Halloween day. And I was so filled with ideas, and things, and emotions, that I didn't really say very much. And again, I couldn't say very much. I think we had a wonderful dinner. They were, of course, glad to see me because they hadn't seen me in a long time. They knew I was coming back, and we had a wonderful dinner.
我在万圣节那天到了他们的房子。我心中充满了想法、事物和情绪，以至于我没有说太多话。再说一次，我确实也说不出什么来。我想我们吃了一顿美餐。他们当然很高兴见到我，因为他们已经很久没见到我了。他们知道我会回来，我们吃了一顿很棒的晚餐。
We had baskets of candy, which I gave out to the kids. And we had a discussion that night which was about nothing in particular. It was not about the future. It was just about, I think, talking about our family and my brothers and sisters. And I was telling them all that I  had learned about them. And so it was a very together and, again, not a very dramatic evening, but just a pleasant one, one that you might have a memory about as you were dying, which was not a special evening, but just an ordinary evening.
我们有几篮糖果，我分给了孩子们。那天晚上我们进行了一场谈话，谈的内容没什么特别的。不是关于未来。我想只是关于我们的家庭，关于我的兄弟姐妹。我告诉他们我所了解到的关于他们的一切。所以那是一个非常温馨的夜晚，再说一次，并不戏剧化，只是一个愉快的夜晚，一个你在临死前可能会回忆起的夜晚——那不是什么特别的夜晚，只是一个平凡的夜晚。
And I went to bed that night, which was a very difficult thing to do because I was fully prepared at that point never to wake up again. I had been praying. I had gotten everything arranged. I had fully gone through in my own mind, in my own soul, all the things that I might have regretted. And I had righted as many of those as I thought I could through letters. And I was prepared, as much as anybody could be prepared to die.
那天晚上我上床睡觉了，这非常困难，因为那时我已经做好准备永远不会再醒来。我一直在祈祷。我已经安排好了一切。在我的脑海里，在我的灵魂深处，我已经彻底梳理了我可能后悔的所有事情。我也通过信件尽可能地纠正了其中的许多事情。我已经像任何准备面对死亡的人一样做好了准备。
And so I went to bed while the kids were still ringing doorbells. And I went to sleep, because I was very tired after that long trip. And I didn't know what was going to happen the next day. I thought I had done all that I could. And the next morning, I woke up. And the next morning, I woke up, and it was as if-- The next morning I woke up, and it was as if I had the entire-- my entire life again.
所以，在孩子们还在按门铃的时候，我就去睡觉了。我睡着了，因为长途跋涉后我非常疲惫。我不知道第二天会发生什么。我以为我已经做了我能做的一切。第二天早上，我醒了。第二天早上，我醒了，感觉就好像……第二天早上我醒来，就好像我又拥有了整个……我又拥有了整个人生。
The next morning, I woke up, and I had my entire life again. I had my future again. There was nothing special about the day. It was another ordinary day. I was reborn into ordinariness. But what more could one ask for?
第二天早上，我醒来，我又拥有了整个人生。我又拥有了未来。这一天并没有什么特别之处。这是又一个平凡的日子。我重生在平凡之中。但一个人还能祈求什么呢？
Well, Kevin Kelly is 43 now. That happened when he was 27. In his latest rebirth, he is the executive editor of Wired magazine, a glossy magazine about the future and the present. He told us that he wasn't even sure he has ever even told his parents this story, even this many years later. Anyway, he spoke with me and Paul Tough from the studios of KQED in San Francisco. This is Your Radio Playhouse on WBEZ Chicago.
好吧，Kevin Kelly现在43岁了。那件事发生在他27岁的时候。在他最新的重生中，他是《连线》杂志的执行主编，那是一本关于未来和当下的精美杂志。他告诉我们，甚至时隔多年，他都不确定自己是否曾向父母讲过这个故事。无论如何，他和我在旧金山KQED的演播室里，还有Paul Tough一起谈了这些。这里是WBEZ芝加哥的《你的广播剧场》。
Good morning. Glass, Jacobson & Associates.
早上好，Glass, Jacobson & Associates 公司。
Hey, is Barry there?
嘿，Barry在吗？
Pardon me?
抱歉，您说什么？
Is Barry there?
Barry在吗？
Yes, he is. He's on another call. Do you wish to hold, or I could take a message, or you can leave one on his voicemail?
是的，他在。他正在接另一个电话。您想留下来等待，还是我帮您留言，或者您可以留在他的语音信箱里？
It's his son.
我是他儿子。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Isn't this starting to sound like-- this little dialogue-- isn't it starting to sound like an episode of Dr. Katz? You know that TV show? "This is his son." "Uh-huh. Yeah." Anyway, so I thought I would call my parents in Baltimore and ask for advice on this, our first evening of our brand new radio show, Your Radio Playhouse.
这听起来不像……这段小小的对话……不像《凯茨医生》里的一集吗？你知道那个电视节目吗？“这是他儿子。”“嗯哼。是啊。”总之，我想给我在巴尔的摩的父母打电话，在这个新广播节目《你的广播剧场》开播的第一晚，向他们征求一下建议。
Can I leave a message with you? Or is it better to use his voicemail?
我可以留话给你吗？还是用他的语音信箱更好？
It doesn't matter. I'll put it right on his voicemail.
没关系。我会直接转到他的语音信箱。
OK, let's do.
好的，就这样吧。
OK, hold on, please.
好的，请稍等。
[MUSIC - "NICE 'N' EASY" BY FRANK SINATRA]
[音乐 - 弗兰克·辛纳屈演唱的《Nice 'n' Easy》]
This is the story of my childhood right there. Dad is a little too busy to talk. But there's the recording of Frank Sinatra when needed.
这简直是我童年生活的写照。爸爸太忙了没空说话。但需要的时候，倒是有弗兰克·辛纳屈的录音。
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Mom.
嘿，妈。
Oh, hi, Ira.
哦，嗨，Ira。
How you doing?
你好吗？
Fine. Can you hold on a second?
挺好的。你能稍等一下吗？
Sure.
当然。
This is what it's like with my parents. They're so busy. Call them. Put on hold. [SINGING] Baby, what's your hurry?
这就是我父母平时的样子。他们太忙了。打给他们。让你挂机等待。[唱歌] 宝贝，你着急什么？
When I call my little sister, she works at Disney, and so there's Disney music playing on the hold system. But there's a lot of Disney music. And there's a lot of it that peo--
当我给我的小妹妹打电话时，她在迪士尼工作，所以候线时会播放迪士尼音乐。但这迪士尼音乐太多了。而且有很多人……
Hi.
喂。
Hi, Mom.
嗨，妈。
Yeah.
嗯。
It's me.
是我。
Yeah.
嗯。
Listen, can I record a quick conversation with you about something?
听着，我能和你录一段简短的对话吗？
What about?
关于什么的？
Well, you know the new show goes on the air this week. And as part of the show, we were thinking about having me call around to different people and get advice from them. And I wanted to know if you would have any advice.
嗯，你知道新节目这周开播。作为节目的一部分，我们想让我给不同的人打电话征求他们的建议。我想知道你有什么建议吗？
Hm. Do I have any advice? Well, can I ask another question?
嗯。我有建议吗？好吧，我可以问个问题吗？
Sure.
当然。
Who is your target audience?
Shirley Glass: 你的目标听众是谁？
You are such a pro.
Ira Glass: 你真是个行家。
I'm saying that you're in danger of appealing to a narrow range of listeners if it becomes a little too-- I don't know what word to use.
Shirley Glass: 我是说，如果受众面变得太——我不知道该用什么词——你可能会面临听众群体过窄的风险。
Artsy.
Ira Glass: 艺术化？
Artsy, yeah.
Shirley Glass: 对，艺术化。
Are you and Dad still worried about me making a living in public radio? I know just for years, you were urging me to just get out and get, basically, any job in TV that I possibly could. But now that I've got my own show, are you guys still worried? Or do you feel like things are going OK? Do you want me to get into television still?
Ira Glass: 你和爸爸还在担心我能不能靠公共广播过活吗？我知道过去好多年，你们一直催我辞职，去电视行业找份工作。但现在我有自己的节目了，你们还担心吗？还是觉得一切都还不错？你们还是想让我进电视圈吗？
Now that Hugh Grant is such a big star, and everybody who sees you or sees your picture thinks how much you look like Hugh Grant, that fires up that TV thing again in me.
Shirley Glass: 既然休·格兰特现在是大明星了，而每个见过你或看过你照片的人都觉得你长得特别像他，这就又让我燃起了让你去干电视的念头。
All right. I'm stopping the tape. This is me live. That was the tape. Only my mother could possibly believe this. Only a mother could pretty much believe this. Other adults see me, and the thought that goes through their head is not Hugh Grant. The thought that goes through their head is tall Jew.
Ira Glass: 好了，我暂停录音了。现在是我在实时说话。刚才那是录音。只有我妈才会相信这种话。真的，只有妈妈才会相信。别的成年人见到我，脑子里闪过的念头可不是休·格兰特，而是“一个高个子犹太人”。
Well, gosh, wouldn't they want this wonderful humanistic, intelligent reporter who looks like Hugh Grant?
Shirley Glass: 哎呀，难道他们就不想拥有这么一位既有人文关怀、聪明睿智，又长得像休·格兰特的记者吗？
All right. Yeah, let's move on.
Ira Glass: 行吧，咱们继续。
What's the theme for this week?
Shirley Glass: 这周的主题是什么？
The theme for this week is new beginnings. And we have several stories, people telling about various ways in which their life began anew at some point.
Ira Glass: 本周的主题是“新的开始”。我们有几个故事，讲述了人们如何在人生的某个节点迎来各种形式的新生。
That's very interesting, because I just did an interview this morning with a newspaper reporter about roman--
Shirley Glass: 这太有趣了，因为今天早上我刚接受了一位报社记者的采访，谈的是浪漫……
I'm just going to stop the tape again. This is my whole life. I call my mom for an interview, and it's not even her first interview of the day. I was lucky to get a booking. She's a therapist, and sometimes she gets called by the papers and stuff.
Ira Glass: 我又要暂停录音了。这就是我的生活常态。我给妈妈打电话想采访她，结果这竟然还不是她今天的第一场采访。我能预约到她都算运气好。她是心理治疗师，报纸之类的媒体经常找她。
--mance, romantic love. And people's expectations about relationships. And one of the things I believe is that there are a lot of people who are good at beginnings, but they're not good at middles.
Shirley Glass: ……浪漫之爱。以及人们对关系的期望。我的观点之一是，很多人擅长开始，但不擅长经营过程。
Which means what?
Ira Glass: 这话怎么讲？
It means that they like the beginning, where there's all this idealization and romantic projections. And the other person can be who they think they should be, rather than who they are. And when they get to the middle phase--
Shirley Glass: 这意味着他们喜欢开始阶段，那时候充满了理想化和浪漫投射。对方可以成为他们心目中认为的样子，而不是真实的自我。当进入中期阶段时……
All right. I'm just going to stop the tape. Listen, all of you in the audience right now, let's just agree right now, it's the very beginning of our relationship. It's the very beginning of our radio relationship right now. This is our little first little radio date, and I just don't want any idealizing on either side. OK? Let's just make eye contact right now. Remember what Joe Franklin said about the eye contact. No idealizing.
Ira Glass: 好了，我要再按一下暂停。听着，现在在听节目的各位，让我们达成共识，现在正是我们这段关系的开端。这是我们广播缘分的起点，是我们第一次广播约会，我可不希望任何一方过度理想化。好吗？我们现在注视着对方。记得乔·富兰克林说过的关于眼神交流的事吗？不要理想化。
--where there's more of a reality-based relationship, they run away from it because it's not as exciting.
Shirley Glass: ……也就是当关系回归现实时，他们就会逃之夭夭，因为觉得没那么刺激了。
It's interesting that you say that because, actually, as we've approached the first show, I've realized that I am much more comfortable with the notion of every day, work-a-day radio work, and being on every week, and having pieces on the air. But the notion of saying in a really big way, "OK, this is the beginning. It's the beginning, and we're going to have a big beginning, and we're going to make an epic statement," I feel very uncomfortable with.
Ira Glass: 你这么说很有趣，因为实际上，随着第一期节目的临近，我意识到我对那种平平淡淡、日复一日的广播工作，以及每周按时播送节目的状态感到自在得多。但如果让我郑重其事地宣布：“好，这是开始。这是一个盛大的开始，我们要做出史诗般的宣言”，我反而会感到非常不适。
So you are good at middles.
Shirley Glass: 所以你擅长经营过程。
I'm better, I think, at middles than at beginnings.
Ira Glass: 我想，我确实比应对开始，更擅长经营过程。
That's good. That's good because practically all of life is the middle.
Shirley Glass: 那很好，那很好，因为人生的绝大部分时间都是过程。
We have gotten so deep here. I never expected that it was going to get so deep. I'm just very pleased at how deep this has gotten. Now you're sitting there, you're thinking, "Is he making fun of me? What's happening now? Where are you?" No, I'm not. I'm not, actually. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. You have nothing to worry about.
Ira Glass: 我们聊得太深了。我从没想过会聊到这个深度。我很高兴能聊得这么深入。现在你坐在那儿肯定在想：“他在取笑我吗？怎么回事？你在哪儿？”不，我没有。真的没有。你不用担心。
Are we going to get a tape of this since we're outside the Chicago listening area?
Shirley Glass: 我们能拿到这期的录音带吗？毕竟我们在芝加哥收听范围之外。
Depending on how you sound, yeah.
Ira Glass: 得看你表现得怎么样吧，可以。
OK.
Shirley Glass: 好吧。
Well, that's my mom, Shirley Glass, speaking to us from Baltimore. I don't think she's going to get a tape. I do not think she's going to get a tape.
Ira Glass: 刚才那是我的母亲 Shirley Glass 在巴尔的摩接受采访。我想她拿不到录音带了。我觉得她拿不到。
Well, next on our little playhouse stage, we have Mr. Lawrence Steger. Now those of you who have been listening carefully to our program and taking notes, and I know there are many of you out there, you know what I'm supposed to do at this point. You know because you were listening carefully to Joe Franklin at the very beginning of our program.
Ira Glass: 好了，接下来在我们的剧场舞台上，我们要请出 Lawrence Steger 先生。各位认真收听我们节目并做笔记的听众——我知道你们大有人在——你们知道我这时候该做什么了。你们知道，因为你们刚才仔细听了 Joe Franklin 在节目开头的叮嘱。
Above all, get the plug fast.
Joe Franklin: 最重要的是，赶紧打广告。
That's right. Well, thank you, Joe Franklin. Lawrence Steger is a filmmaker and a performance artist, just back from performing in Glasgow, Scotland. He's going back there in January to collaborate with the performance artist, Ron Athey, who lives here in Chicago. And basically, we contacted Lawrence, and we told him the story that you heard over the course of the last half-hour, Kevin Kelly's story, this guy who believes he only has six months to live, goes on this cross-country road trip.
Ira Glass: 没错，谢谢你，Joe Franklin。Lawrence Steger 是一位电影制作人和行为艺术家，刚从苏格兰格拉斯哥的演出回来。一月份他还要回去，与住在芝加哥的行为艺术家 Ron Athey 合作。我们联系了 Lawrence，告诉他你们在过去半小时里听到的故事，也就是 Kevin Kelly 的故事，这个被告知只剩六个月寿命的人，决定踏上横跨全国的公路旅行。
And as it turned out, when Lawrence Steger found out, the day that he found out that he was HIV positive, this was five years ago, on that day, it was the exact day that he and a friend left on a cross-country car trip. So we commissioned him to do a little piece about his experience. And here it is.
Ira Glass: 巧合的是，Lawrence Steger 五年前得知自己 HIV 呈阳性的那一天，正是他和朋友出发进行横跨全国公路旅行的日子。于是我们委托他创作了一段关于那段经历的小短片。下面就请听。
Title. Road. Treatment. It's shot entirely on video, mostly handheld. Shaky, out of focus, bad color. Overblown color actually. Sort of the way colors are separated on an old television console, yet still has all the outlines of the images repeated. The outlines of the images, the silhouettes, repeated over and over, ad nauseam, and fading into each other.
Lawrence Steger: 标题：路。治疗。视频全是用手持摄像机拍的。画面晃动，对焦不准，色彩糟糕。其实是色彩过曝了。就像老式电视机里的颜色分离，图像的轮廓反复重叠，一直叠到让人厌烦，最后融为一体。
Can I get this microphone adjusted a little, so I don't have to lean over so much?
Lawrence Steger: 能帮我调一下麦克风吗？这样我就不用弯着腰了。
Yeah, sure. Just pull that.
Ira Glass: 当然，拉一下那个就行。
Check one, two, three. Sound better? Yeah. Sorry. Thanks.
Lawrence Steger: 喂，一、二、三。声音好点了吗？好的。抱歉，谢了。
Synopsis. The story concerns Luke, gay, white, Midwestern, late twenties. Follows Luke on the day that he is informed of his HIV positive status. Luke cops a stance of cold, brittle, not unlike the Harrison Ford narration on Blade Runner, but there's a hint of vulnerability to Luke.
Lawrence Steger: 剧情大纲。故事关于 Luke，男，同性恋，白人，来自中西部，二十多岁。讲述 Luke 在得知自己 HIV 阳性当天发生的事。Luke 摆出一副冷漠、僵硬的态度，有点像《银翼杀手》里哈里森·福特的旁白，但 Luke 的内心深处还有一丝脆弱。
Have we got the Harrison Ford or the Rutger Hauer voice?
Lawrence Steger: 我们用的是哈里森·福特的声音还是鲁特格尔·哈尔的声音？
Yeah.
Ira Glass: 对。
Great. Roll it.
Lawrence Steger: 好极了，播放。
Enhance 5719. Track 45 left.
Harrison Ford: 增强 5719。追踪左侧 45 度。
Great. Take it under me. That's great. Story follows Luke. He's accompanied by his college buddy, Bill, and both are packed for a road trip across the country to San Francisco.
Lawrence Steger: 太棒了，把背景音乐调小。就这样。故事跟随 Luke。他由大学好友 Bill 陪同，两人打好行囊，准备开车横跨全国前往旧金山。
This isn't the right section of Blade Runner. Can you just kill the Blade Runner?
Lawrence Steger: 这不是《银翼杀手》合适的那一段。能把《银翼杀手》的声音关了吗？
Locations. Car interior. Gas station exterior. HIV clinic parking lot. HIV clinic interior. Highway. Music. Strauss's four last songs, particularly "Ruhe, meine Seele!" sung by Dame Janet Baker.
Lawrence Steger: 地点。车内。加油站外。艾滋病诊所停车场。诊所内部。高速公路。音乐。施特劳斯的《最后四首歌》，特别是 Dame Janet Baker 演唱的《休息吧，我的灵魂！》。
Can you take it under me? Hold.
Lawrence Steger: 能把音量调小吗？停一下。
Follows Luke and his friend Bill to the gas station and to the clinic, the last stop before getting on the highway.
Lawrence Steger: 讲述 Luke 和朋友 Bill 前往加油站和诊所的过程，那是上高速公路前的最后一站。
OK. Take it out. Take out the Janet Baker.
Lawrence Steger: 好的。切掉。把 Janet Baker 的歌切掉。
Bill loads one hits of pot while driving on the way to the gas station and to the clinic.
Lawrence Steger: Bill 在去往加油站和诊所的路上边开车边抽大麻。
Can we nix that Strauss music? It's too mournful. There's really no music on the soundtrack. It's stark, crisp. Maybe some songs coming from the radio at the clinic's desk?
Lawrence Steger: 能把那段施特劳斯的音乐撤了吗？太哀伤了。原声带里其实根本没音乐。应该是清冷、干脆的感觉。也许诊所前台的收音机里传出几首歌？
[RADIO STATIC]
Lawrence Steger: [收音机静电噪声]
Great. And definitely from the car radio mixed with surfing on an AM radio. No music.
太棒了。这绝对是车里的收音机混合着AM电台搜台的声音。没有音乐。
The drama is constantly being undermined through the cool, collective quality of Luke's demeanor. He seems detached, quote, "I am not sure how I feel. I feel a little sad, sort of mad. I guess blank. But I'm OK. I'm sure I'll get a handle on it," end quote. Luke thinks he's sounding like a short story assignment in a creative writing class or, worse, trapped inside an artsy novel.
卢克（Luke）那冷静、沉稳的举止不断地消解着剧情的张力。他显得很超脱，引用他的话说：“我不确定自己是什么感觉。我感到有点难过，也有点生气。我想是一片空白吧。但我还行。我相信我会处理好的。”卢克自认为听起来像创意写作课上的短篇小说作业，或者更糟的是，觉得自己被困在了一部矫揉造作的小说里。
Luke imagines himself in a television dramatization of himself. Camera pulls back from behind Luke's head, sort of on a mini-crane. Camera floats, hovers over the back of Luke's head. "The ceiling of the car must be incredibly high," he thinks to himself.
卢克想象自己置身于一部关于他自己的电视改编剧中。摄像机从卢克脑后拉开，像是在一个小摇臂上。镜头浮动着，盘旋在卢克脑后。他心里想：“车顶一定高得离谱。”
Bill pulls into the closest parking spot in the clinic, blows out the last of the one-hit, and, as he's knocking the brass pipe into the ashtray, turns to Luke with that slightly watery look in his eyes from too much intake. Luke takes it as one of those Care Bear looks that he's experienced before from Bill. A little clumsy since Bill has to force his face into a sympathetic posture. Quick close-up on the corner of Bill's mouth.
比尔（Bill）把车停在诊所最近的停车位上，呼出最后一口烟，当他把铜烟斗在烟灰缸里磕掉时，转过头看向卢克。因为吸多了，他的眼睛看起来有点湿润。卢克把它看作是比尔之前对他那种“爱心熊”式的关怀。这动作有点笨拙，因为比尔不得不强迫自己的脸摆出一副同情的表情。镜头快速特写比尔的嘴角。
There's a moment of anger flashing in Luke when he registers Bill's look. When Bill asks him, "What are you thinking about?" Luke responds, "Who's thinking? Nothing." "I hate thinking I'm in a novel," he thinks to himself. Cut to interior of the clinic, the reception area.
当卢克注意到比尔的表情时，心中闪过一丝愤怒。当比尔问他：“你在想什么？”卢克回答说：“谁在想？什么也没想。”他心里暗想：“我讨厌那种觉得自己活在小说里的感觉。”切到诊所内部，接待处。
Can we change this sound bed here?
我们能换一下这里的背景音乐吗？
[ROMANTIC MUSIC PLAYING]
[浪漫的音乐响起]
Great. Take it down just a-- Great.
太棒了。稍微调低一点——很好。
In the scene that we talked about on the phone, the clinic waiting room scene, that scene flips back and forth between various security black-and-white cameras mounted at the ceilings. The nurse assigned to Luke's anonymous number is a black drag queen named Stephanie, who wears a full nurse's outfit complete with a little paper hat that sits atop of her freshly coiffed hairdo. She's the only one in the clinic who wears a real uniform. Stephanie has the longest fingernails that Luke has ever seen on anyone. Luke thinks briefly about how the fingernails keep on growing even after a person dies, but he pushes that thought away with this fingers to his forehead, wonders why he is thinking about that. It's that novel thing again.
在我们电话里谈过的那场戏，就是诊所候诊室的那场戏，镜头在天花板上安装的各种黑白监控摄像头之间来回切换。分配给卢克匿名编号的护士是一位名叫斯蒂芬妮（Stephanie）的黑人变装皇后，她穿着全套护士服，发型精心打理过，上面还顶着一顶小纸帽。她是诊所里唯一穿正式制服的人。斯蒂芬妮留着卢克见过的人中最长的指甲。卢克简短地想到指甲在人死后还会继续生长，但他用手指抵住前额，把这个念头推开了，奇怪自己为什么会想这个。又是那种小说里的东西在作祟。
Stephanie, the drag queen nurse, walks Luke back to the small cubicles that the tests are administered in and then used to relay the results. Luke's narrator imagines how many people have been in these cubicles and what they would look like if they were all piled on top of one another. Piles of tested bodies. Cut to Stephanie closing the hollow core door, makes that hollow core door sound.
变装皇后护士斯蒂芬妮领着卢克回到进行测试的小隔间，那里也用于传达结果。卢克的叙述者想象着有多少人曾经待过这些隔间，如果把他们全都堆在一起会是什么样子。堆积如山的被测试者尸体。切到斯蒂芬妮关上那扇空心门，发出那种空心门关上的声音。
Do we have that on cart?
我们有那段音效吗？
[SOUND OF HOLLOW DOOR CLOSING]
[空心门关上的声音]
Perfect. Maybe a shot from a security camera that shows all of the cubicles in the clinic. Luke imagines himself in a George Tooker painting that was reproduced in his sixth grade reader. He wonders what his sixth grade teacher would think of Stephanie. He wonders if his sixth grade teacher was ever tested. He imagines her body in the pileup of bodies who have come to the clinic.
完美。或许可以来一个监控摄像头的镜头，拍到诊所里所有的隔间。卢克想象自己置身于一幅乔治·图克（George Tooker）的画中，那是他六年级课本里印刷过的作品。他想知道他的六年级老师会对斯蒂芬妮有什么看法。他好奇他的六年级老师是否也被检测过。他想象着她的身体也在那些来到诊所的人堆里。
Stephanie has been saying something, and Luke has to blink his eyes again to refocus. He explains to Stephanie that he has been expecting this result, that he's experienced a large share of AIDS, cared for, and, likewise, buried lots of his friends. But it doesn't seem to come as a surprise. Stephanie says, "You can cry or hold my hand. I just want you to sit for a moment and let it sink in." Luke thinks, "Whatever."
斯蒂芬妮一直在说着什么，卢克不得不再次眨眼让自己回过神来。他向斯蒂芬妮解释说他早就预料到了这个结果，他经历过很多艾滋病病例，照顾过，也埋葬过很多朋友。但这似乎并没有让他感到意外。斯蒂芬妮说：“你可以哭出来，或者握住我的手。我只是想让你坐一会儿，让情绪沉淀一下。”卢克心想：“随便吧。”
Cut to Bill in waiting room, flipping through People 's The Year in Pictures. Cut back to close-up of Luke, forehead wrinkled. He thinks his narrator wants him to get out of the cubicle. He waits for Stephanie to finish her spiel, thanks her, and shakes her hand, getting a slight scrape from one of the fingernails. Close-up on Luke's hand, no scratch. The walls seem to pulsate as Luke walks down the hallway to the reception area. He tries to be as blank as possible to Bill.
切到坐在候诊室里的比尔，翻看着《人物》杂志的《年度图片》。切回卢克的特写，眉头紧锁。他觉得他的叙述者想让他离开隔间。他等着斯蒂芬妮说完那些客套话，感谢了她，并与她握手，指甲在他手上划了一下。特写卢克的手，没有抓痕。当卢克走回接待处时，墙壁似乎在脉动。他努力在比尔面前表现得尽可能空白。
I'm not sure about this final section. I know that we talked about it ending on the highway with the car being surrounded by bikers on their way to the Sturgis bikers' rally. But now I like the idea of it ending on the highway entrance ramp.
我不确定这最后一段。我知道我们讨论过以高速公路为结尾，车子被一群前往斯特吉斯摩托车集会的骑手包围。但现在我喜欢以高速公路入口匝道结尾的创意。
Cut to interior of car pulling out of parking lot. Luke keeps looking straight ahead, as he murmurs, "I'm positive." Long, slow pan from the back of Luke's head to the back of Bill's. There's no reaction in either of their faces or, better, the profiles of their faces. This is the longest shot. They don't look at each other.
切到车内，车辆驶离停车场。卢克一直直视前方，喃喃自语：“我是阳性。”一个长长的、缓慢的推镜头，从卢克的后脑勺移到比尔的后脑勺。他们的脸上都没有什么反应，或者说，侧脸的轮廓上没有反应。这是最长的一个镜头。他们没有看对方。
Perhaps this scene would be shot in blue screen with the camera in the backseat and the sky surrounding the two heads of Bill and Luke having that old, scratchy, 16 millimeter time lapse exposure, so the clouds seem to be moving at a rapid pace. Flickers, flips back and forth between real sky and blue screen backdrop. Voice comes up on a car radio. "Trying not to think of the future. Just live in the present moment." Something like that. You got that? It comes onto the radio.
也许这场戏可以用蓝幕拍摄，摄像机放在后座，比尔和卢克的两个头周围的天空有着那种老式、带划痕的16毫米延时曝光效果，云层看起来在快速移动。画面在真实天空和蓝幕背景之间闪烁跳动。汽车收音机里传出声音。“尽量不要去想未来。活在当下。”类似这样的话。你听到了吗？声音从收音机里传出来。
I also decided that it was an entirely unnatural and inhumane way to live, and that having a future is part of what being human is about, and that when you take away the future for humans, you take away a lot of the humanness, and that it's not actually a very good thing to live entirely in the present, that one needs to have a past.
我还认定那是一种极其不自然且不人道的生活方式，拥有未来是身为人类的一部分。当你剥夺了人类的未来，你就剥夺了很大一部分人性。事实上，完全活在当下并不是一件好事，人需要有过去。
Luke comments to Bill, "Live entirely in the present, huh?" Bill drives and looks out the corner of his right eye to see what position Luke is holding his head in. Luke looks outside passenger window and, every once in a while, turns to glance at Bill. Long pause. There's dead air. Cut to Luke's point of view. Car is pulling onto entrance ramp of highway. Luke sees hitchhiker with a sign that he stands for any remote meaning to the narrative. Luke sees himself outside of his own story. He can't read the hitchhiker's sign. He knows that he's on a long silent journey. He leans over to turn off the radio. Cut to black.
卢克对一旁的比尔说：“活在当下，哈？”比尔开着车，用右眼余光瞥了一眼卢克正以什么姿势低着头。卢克看着副驾窗外，偶尔转头看一眼比尔。长久的停顿。出现了死寂。切到卢克的视角。车子正开上高速公路的入口匝道。卢克看到一个举着牌子的搭车人，他代表着叙事中任何遥远的意义。卢克看到了故事之外的自己。他读不懂搭车人的牌子。他知道自己正处于一段漫长的沉默旅程中。他俯身关掉了收音机。画面切黑。
[MUSIC - "(UH-OH) GET OUT OF THE CAR" BY THE TRENIERS]
[音乐 - The Treniers 演唱的 “(Uh-Oh) Get Out of the Car”]
Well, Lawrence Steger is a Chicago performance artist and filmmaker.
嗯，劳伦斯·斯蒂格（Lawrence Steger）是一位芝加哥的行为艺术家和电影制作人。
This is Your Radio Playhouse. I'm Ira Glass. OK, what am I doing right now? What am I doing right now? That's right. That's right. Eye contact.
这里是《广播剧场》（Your Radio Playhouse）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。好吧，我现在在做什么？我现在在做什么？没错。没错。眼神交流。
Look right in the eye. Eye contact is everything.
直视眼睛。眼神交流就是一切。
That's right. Advice from the master. OK. Let's review our program so far. Let's just review. Let's just get things straight right now. Our stories so far have been about people whose futures were taken from them and were thrown into the present in one way or another.
说得对。来自大师的建议。好的。让我们回顾一下我们的节目。让我们理一理。把事情搞清楚。到目前为止，我们的故事讲述的都是那些未来被剥夺，以各种方式被抛入当下的人们。
I guess when any big emotional moment happens, you are thrown in the present in a really aggressive, aggressive way, whether you choose to or not. You have this hyper sense of reality. Well, the next story is about someone whose future was taken from him when he was wrongly imprisoned for 20 years. And his sentence was commuted two years ago. And he found himself reborn into everyday life.
我想每当重大情感时刻发生时，你都会以一种非常剧烈的方式被抛入当下，无论你是否选择这么做。你会有一种对现实的超强感知。那么，下一个故事讲述的是一个未来被剥夺的人，他被错误监禁了20年。他的刑期在两年前减免了。他发现自己重生到了日常生活中。
It was like I just-- I don't know. It seemed like the oxygen was even different. You know what I mean? The air seemed to be thinner.
就好像我……我不知道。感觉氧气似乎都不一样了。你明白我的意思吗？空气好像变得稀薄了。
I'll tell you what's been a real kick for me, getting up, cooking breakfast. Making pancakes, and eggs, and bacon, and stuff like that. It sounds drab maybe to the common-- everybody would think of that as, "That's really drab." But for me, that's really exciting. And that's one of the things I always dreamed of doing. I also dreamt of finding a very lovely lady, and I have. Inside, I'm happy. Inside.
我告诉你什么对我来说是一种真正的乐趣，那就是起床，做早餐。做煎饼、鸡蛋、培根之类的东西。对普通人来说，这听起来可能很枯燥——大家都觉得，“那真是太枯燥了。”但对我来说，这非常令人兴奋。这是我一直梦想做的事情之一。我还梦想着找到一位可爱的女士，我也找到了。内心深处，我很幸福。内心深处。
This is Ed Ryder. He was in prison for murder and was doing time in Graterford Prison in Pennsylvania. And a few years ago, a key witness who had testified against him admitted to lying while under oath, and other evidence came forward. He was made a free man. Back when he was in Graterford Prison, he played trumpet, and he sang with a jazz band. And that whole time, he dreamed of this new life, a new life that he would have outside as a professional musician. And that's what he's working on. That's what he's working on right now. And he's playing. He doesn't have a CD yet, but he's playing gigs in the real world.
这是埃德·莱德（Ed Ryder）。他因谋杀罪入狱，在宾夕法尼亚州的格雷特福德（Graterford）监狱服刑。几年前，一名曾对他作证的关键证人承认在宣誓后撒谎，其他证据也浮出水面。他恢复了自由。在格雷特福德监狱时，他吹小号，并在爵士乐队里唱歌。那整段时间里，他梦想着这种新生活，一种他在狱外作为职业音乐家拥有的新生活。这就是他正在努力的目标。他现在正在为此而努力。他还在演奏。他还没有CD，但他正在现实世界里参加演出。
The first time I played, when I got out of prison, I didn't feel compelled to be so exact like I did when I was at Graterford. Inmates are the worst, critical people in the world. They criticize anything you do. In prison, you have a lot of musicians. After all, musicians, they don't make no money, so I guess the first place you find them at is in prison. But you have a lot of guys who are musicians.
当我出狱后第一次演奏时，我并不觉得有必要像在格雷特福德时那样精准。囚犯是世界上最刻薄的评论家。他们会批评你做的任何事。在监狱里，有很多音乐家。毕竟，音乐家赚不到钱，所以我想你最先找到他们的地方就是监狱。那里有很多搞音乐的人。
And even though they might not be actively playing anymore, they'll be quick to criticize you, whether the chord is not right, or whether you didn't flatten the ninth, whether you didn't raise this fifth, or you guys didn't play the changes right. Although it might not have took away from the structure of the music, it's just that, I guess you can say that prisoners have a tendency to think like classical musicians would. Everything has to be perfect and exact the way it's heard. And everything has to be like that. There's no going against the grain.
即使他们可能不再活跃地演奏了，他们也会很快地批评你，不管是和弦不对，还是你没降九音，或者你没升五音，或者你们没按乐谱弹对。虽然这可能并没有破坏音乐的结构，但我想你可以说囚犯们倾向于像古典音乐家那样思考。一切都必须完美，必须和听到的完全一样。一切都必须那样。没有商量的余地。
And here, in the world, people are a little different. They don't concern themselves so much with that, as much as how are you entertaining us? How are you helping us to feel better about ourselves? How are you making us feel better? At Graterford, there is nothing you can do to make them feel better, except to release them.
而在外面，在现实世界里，人们有点不同。他们并不太关心那些，更关心的是你如何娱乐我们？你如何帮我们感觉更好？你如何让我们开心？在格雷特福德，你除了释放他们，没什么能让他们感觉更好。
So if you can play for a Graterford audience, you don't even look for an applause. Just as long as they don't boo you, you're all right. If they can't find nothing wrong with the music, they'll tell you, "You just didn't turn right. When you had the horn up, you didn't hold it on a 45 degree angle. It didn't look right." So they'll find something.
所以如果你能在格雷特福德的观众面前演奏，你甚至不需要掌声。只要他们不嘘你，你就还好。如果他们实在找不出音乐有什么毛病，他们就会告诉你，“你刚才转得不对。你举起号的时候，没把它保持在45度角。看起来不对劲。”所以他们总能找到些毛病。
Now you know how we heard people earlier in the program talk about the importance of living in the present. But when we interviewed Ed Ryder, he pointed out that, in prison, the most important thing is to keep your eye on the future, on the day that you're going to get out. And that the guys who just live in the present do really badly, because, of course, the present is so terrible.
现在你知道我们为什么在节目早些时候听到人们谈论活在当下的重要性了。但当我们采访埃德·莱德时，他指出，在监狱里，最重要的是盯着未来，盯着你出狱的那一天。那些只活在当下的人过得很惨，因为当然了，现实是非常可怕的。
I think when I was in prison, I dreamed more about the future in my head. I just had a lot of plans, a lot of things that I just dreamed about, I just dreamed of doing and dreamed of accomplishing. You're forced almost to. You know what I mean? You have nothing else to look forward to but tomorrow. You're constantly hoping and hoping. You're trying to plan something for the future.
我想我在监狱里时，脑子里更多是在梦想未来。我有很多计划，很多我梦想着做和梦想着完成的事情。你几乎被迫这样做。你明白我的意思吗？你除了明天别无他盼。你不断地希望，再希望。你努力为未来做点计划。
We asked him if he is still playing the same music now that his future is here and he's out. And we thought that maybe the songs that he used to play would just bring back these hard memories of prison that he'd rather just as soon avoid. But he said, no, he plays the same numbers now that he used to, though sometimes they mean something different to him today.
我们问他，既然未来已经到来，他已经出狱，他是否还在演奏同样的音乐。我们原以为他过去演奏的歌曲会带回那些他宁愿避开的痛苦回忆。但他说，不，他现在还在演奏同样的曲目，尽管有时它们在今天对他有了不同的意义。
When I was in Graterford, I always listened to it. I had a tape of "God Bless the Child That's Got His Own" by Billie Holiday. And what it meant to me when I was at Graterford-- and it has the same meaning now, but it's different. In the sense that, when I was at Graterford, when she said, "Them that's got shall get, Them that's not shall lose. So the Bible says, and it still is news. Mama may have, Papa may have, But God bless the child that has his own."
在格雷特福德时，我经常听它。我有一盘比莉·荷莉黛（Billie Holiday）的《God Bless the Child That's Got His Own》的磁带。它在格雷特福德时对我的意义——它现在还有同样的意义，但又有所不同。从某种意义上说，当我在格雷特福德时，当她唱到：“富有者将得更多，贫穷者将失去。圣经如是说，这依然是新闻。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑那些有自己独立资产的孩子。”
Well, in my mind, at Graterford, I thought that, yes, I was the child that had his own, because I was out here on my own. I had no help at the time. There was no hope. I seen no way. I was like a child. I was like a child because I had no one I can turn to. My parents had passed. I had no one I could turn to.
嗯，在我的脑海里，在格雷特福德，我想，是的，我就是那个有自己资产的孩子，因为我是在这里靠自己。当时我没有任何帮助。没有希望。我看不到出路。我像个孩子。我像个孩子是因为我无人可求。我的父母已经去世了。我无人可求。
And I felt like every time I would listen to that, I felt as though she was talking directly to me. And for me, that meant that I was on my own in this prison situation. And I was going to have to make it the best way that I could. And I was going to have to muster all the energy that I could possibly muster. Now when I was released and I heard the same song again, it still had that meaning, but now it's a different-- I'm on my own differently because I'm not in prison anymore.
我觉得每当我听那首歌，我都觉得她是在直接对我说话。对我来说，这意味着我在那种监狱状况下是靠自己。我必须尽我所能做到最好。我必须鼓起我所能鼓起的所有能量。现在当我出狱后再次听到同一首歌时，它仍然有那种意义，但现在它不同了——我以一种不同的方式靠自己，因为我不在监狱里了。
That's not the struggle no more. It's me. But I'm on my own now because I've got things that I have to do. I have responsibilities now that I have to take care of. I have bills that I have to pay. I have job responsibility.
那不再是斗争了。那是我。但我现在是靠自己，因为我有很多事情要做。我现在有必须要承担的责任。我有账单要付。我有工作职责。
I have a lot of other things that I have to do, and I have to do these things on my own now. I don't have no prison guards waking me up in the morning, telling me, "Hey, it's time to get up," or "It's time to go eat, " or "It's time where you guys can go to a shower." I don't have that anymore. I'm on my own. So all this now is dependent upon me and my own initiative.
我还有很多其他要做的事情，而且我现在必须靠自己去做这些事。没有监狱看守早上把我叫醒，告诉我，“嘿，该起床了，”或者“该去吃饭了，”或者“你们可以去洗澡了。”我不再有这些了。我是靠自己。所以这一切现在都取决于我和我自己的主动性。
[SINGING] Them that's got shall get, them that's not will lose. So the Bible said, and it still is news. Mama may have, Papa may have, but God bless the child that's got his own, that's got his own. You know the strong get more, while the weak ones fade. Empty pockets don't, they don't make the grade. Mama may have, Papa may have, but God bless the child that's got his own, that's got his own. Money, you've got lots of friends. They all keep hanging around your door. But when money's gone and all of the spendings end, they don't come around, they won't come around no more. Rich relations give a crust of bread and such. Go on and help yourself, but you better not take too much. Mama may have, Papa may have, but God bless the child that's got his own. God bless the child that's got his own.
[唱歌] 富有者将得更多，贫穷者将失去。圣经如是说，这依然是新闻。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑那些有自己资产的孩子，有自己资产的孩子。你知道强者得到的更多，而弱者却消逝。空空的口袋，他们，他们无法达到标准。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑那些有自己资产的孩子，有自己资产的孩子。钱，你有很多朋友。他们都一直徘徊在你的门前。但当钱花光了，花费结束了，他们就不会再来了，他们再也不会来了。富有的亲戚会给一点面包之类的东西。去帮你自己吧，但你最好别拿太多。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑那些有自己资产的孩子。上帝保佑那些有自己资产的孩子。
That's basically some of it.
基本上就是这样。
Ed Ryder joining us in the playhouse from the studios of WHYY in Philadelphia, speaking with me and associate producer Nancy Updike. Ed Ryder's a big Billie Holiday fanatic. That was the word he used, "fanatic," when we asked him about it. So when we asked him to play a number with his horn, with his trumpet, he played "Lover Man."
埃德·莱德从费城WHYY工作室加入我们的剧场，与我和副制作人南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）交谈。埃德·莱德是比莉·荷莉黛的超级粉丝。这是我们问他时他用的词，“狂热者”。所以当我们请他用他的号，用他的小号吹奏一首曲子时，他选择了《Lover Man》。
[MUSIC - "LOVER MAN" BY BILLIE HOLIDAY]
[音乐 - 比莉·荷莉黛的《Lover Man》]
That's pretty much all the time we have for this evening.
今晚的时间差不多了。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
This show was produced by Dolores Wilber, Peter Clowney, Nancy Updike, Alix Spiegel, and myself. Contributing editors Paul Tough and Jack Hitt on the west coast, Margy Rochlin on the east coast. I've got that backwards. Paul Tough and Jack Hitt on the east coast. Margy Rochlin on the west. You see, you get so confused when you have two pieces of music running at the same time.
本节目由多洛雷斯·威尔伯（Dolores Wilber）、彼得·克劳尼（Peter Clowney）、南希·厄普代克、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和我本人制作。特约编辑：西海岸的保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）和杰克·希特（Jack Hitt），东海岸的玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）。我搞反了。保罗·塔夫和杰克·希特在东海岸，玛吉·罗克林在西海岸。你看，当你有两段音乐同时播放时，人会变得非常困惑。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Torey Malatia has supported this show from the start. We'll be back next week, same time, we hope. From WBEZ Chicago, I'm Ira Glass.
托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）从一开始就支持这个节目。希望下周同一时间我们能回来。这里是芝加哥WBEZ，我是艾拉·格拉斯。